(slow music)
- Eagle feathers give us
that strength and courage
to go on.
They've been in our
ceremonies for centuries.
And to be able to have these feathers
in our time of prayer,
in our time of need,
is really important to us.
(slow upbeat music)
- We're at the National Eagle Repository.
Last year we received
right at 2,700 eagles
that were found dead or died
for one reason or another
and we provide loose feathers from eagles
to Native Americans for their religious
and cultural purposes.
They are protected by various laws
such as the Bald and
Golden Eagle Protection Act
so people can't just go picking them up.
But this way, it allows Native Americans
a lawful way to obtain and possess eagles.
The birds that we get have
died from various causes.
They often collide with something
that causes them to break a wing
and, of course, results in death,
but usually those
injuries are pretty minor
to the feathers, so we could still use
most of the feathers.
So we're checking what
needs to be replaced there
or what feathers need to be added in,
in an effort to try to
give them the equivalent
of one whole bird.
- The role of the
National Eagle Repository,
it's very important.
It helps us to keep going with our lives
that we know it.
- It's good to know that
you're a part of something
that means so much to a group of people
and that you're playing a role
in protecting a very treasured resource.